et you look different than the last time
I saw you more Canadian maybe yeah
dinner head smaller eyes warmer maybe
warmer I don't know is ET cold I don't
know why anyway let's get down to maybe
when he started really needing to phone
home in the latter stages of the story
Oh what were you talking about ET our
compatriots in the states do the same
thing ah Steven Spielberg's et the
you're talking about the
extra-terrestrial you work for the
extra-terrestrial media company let's go
let's do this interview I'm ready I've
just been waiting for you guys to find
me what I really like about you a number
of things you're so animated on this
carpet I could watch you all night but
the first and foremost you get out there
with your fans you take pictures you
meet them you sign things why is that so
important to you what's the joy of this
whole I mean this is why this is why we
do it to have a connection you know we
as artists we seek connection we try to
communicate and for me this is a special
case because I'm a huge Harry Potter fan
so this I don't know this is like being
embraced by your own community more than
really a actor to fan dynamic you know
any special warm welcome from these fans
here in Toronto in Canada how excited is
it to to be embraced into this whole
world this different world that you're
not used to this Harry Potter world it's
wonderful I mean for me what I'd say is
that fans who are devoted to the
material are already involved in this
world right because because you live the
ethos of Harry Potter you embody the
morality the these ideas about loving
one another and about friendship about
courage you are already in this world
you know and you're already in the JK
Rowling universe if you were a devoted
fan so in some ways I've been in this
universe since I was seven and now I
just get to continue it's a blessing
it's a blessing you get
you're gonna be in this movie how does
that make you feel what goes through
your mind it was really um yeah it was a
very special moment in which I think
there was so much joy in my body that I
could have burst I sort of had a moment
of temporary insanity and Jubilee on the
streets of New York City
got a couple awkward stairs and had to
evacuate the premises quickly after
recovering can you compare the Justice
League fans to comic book fans to the
Harry Potter fans I think there's a you
find this diehard level of devotion in
both places and I think both of these
stories are you know uh sort of modern
mythologies that people really do use as
a source of information and inspiration
in the way that they live their lives
you know and I mean it becomes a huge
part of people's realities and I think
it benefits people largely to have to
have fantasy like that to have story I
think it's really good for us it as
individuals and collectively as a
culture to have these stories that we
can all refer to like you know so you
can be like you know stop being you're
really um bridging me right now you know
it's I'm going to be like whoa that's
horrible I'm so sorry
because we have a we have a vernacular
mutually understood vernacular based on
these stories we all know you're being
pulled away but lastly the
when the Titan it's hits hard for you
I'm assuming to get away from the tights
of the flash you just live in them you
love them come yeah yeah once I you know
once I fat once you find tights there's
there's really there's really no going
back because your legs are just swaddled
like wee babes in blankets
it's so aerodynamic it's true I mean
it's true if I fell over it would happen
quicker